قالت مديره صندوق النقد الدولي كريستالينا
جورديفا ان الاتحاد الاوروبي تضرر بشده
جراء الحرب في اوكرانيا وحضرت من ان نصف
دوليه قد تدخل الركود العام المقبل وعن
اداء الاقتصاد العالمي قالت جورجي فا ان
ثلث اقتصادات العالم قد تدخل في حاله
الركود هذا العام
ناصر
الاقتصاد العالمي ستكون السنه الجديده
اصعب من العام الماضي لماذا لان
الاقتصادات الثلاثه الكبرى الولايات
المتحده والاتحاد الاوروبي والصين
تتباطؤوا جميعها في وقت واحد نتوقع ان
يدخل الثلث اقتصاد العالم في حاله ركود
حتى الدول التي لن يحدث فيها ركود سيشعر
الملايين من مواطنها به ولكن مرونه سوق
العمل في الولايات المتحده قد تساعد
العالم على اجتياز من صعب للغايه